you have had one of the most amazing
months that a human being can have let's
check it out
you win the World Series okay and then
right after winning Game seven of the
World Series your team wins you fly to
Italy am I correct yeah to Mary Kate
Upton that's that's a dream I had once
that's not a real thing that happens to
anybody you know this is real life right
now no no this is yeah this is trust me
you'll see this is quite real very soon
no but I'm curious I'm just very curious
like what's how do you how do you match
that I mean what's next month gonna be
like what do you do from here downhill
yeah exactly
no thing to tell you why Yeah right it's
all downhill from now excited about that
man I don't I don't know it's kind of
like you kind of want to decompress yes
but you you're on such a high that like
we went on our honeymoon and we wanted
to like chill out hey we're just gonna
relax and we're gonna take a few days
and not do anything well day number one
we kind of did that day number two we
wake up and it's like what we do now
right you know you've got you've got not
only adrenaline from getting married but
also winning the World Series we've got
both of those Adrenaline's combined so
you first of all you were late for your
own wedding weren't you yes
you know we planned this thing obviously
a year in advance you know and we did a
destination wedding in Italy and so
there's no really changing that so we
decided that talking through this
there's only one thing that could really
screw up our plans Game seven of the
World Series so sure enough you know we
find ourselves in Game seven the World
Series doesn't it suck
thank you make plans and everything just
goes to [ __ ] yeah well that's what he
kept telling herself it leases for a
great reason a great reason yeah and
then we were getting we're getting
FaceTime calls cuz it was a destination
wedding people we had people there early
we're getting FaceTime calls from our
guests we had a party planned and we're
still in LA haven't even played game
seven yet we're getting FaceTime calls
from our guests saying hey your weddings
beautiful wish you were here yeah at
least they knew if it's not like anyone
was stupid enough to go like where are
you why aren't you here right now so at
least you know I mean what an incredible
what an incredible experience so you
show up late you late for your own
wedding oh you have the wedding okay but
you also had games and things that you
would organize with the guests didn't
you yes so we showed up obviously being
a few days we planned a game day which
you know we split up all our guests into
teams and had colors different colors
and teams and we scheduled a day of you
know like cornhole and ping pong and
balloon throws you know see how far you
can throw the balloon and not break it
what's it like when you throw a balloon
does it go a hundred miles an hour and
actually tear someone's face off you
ruined more fun Tasi games anybody here
he comes
yeah they all kind of did sound like
throwing game yeah that's true - I like
how you like how you arranged it so it's
not a trivial pursuing let's chuck stuff
around let's see how accurate your are
throwing something right just for Kate
like it's walking on a stage game pretty
good she is good so we're off the plane
we literally fly you know game seven
celebrate wake up the next morning early
fly straight to our venue we get off the
plane and walk straight into another
competition right which you know I of
course I lost the first game of ping
pong I played and I'm like that's it I
used up all my karma yeah you ruined
your arm playing ping pong
get your now I would imagine you are a
competitive guide you get competitive
with Kate when you two are playing games
we we have come to the conclusion that
we have to be on the same team if we're
not on the same team it doesn't go so
yes a marriage counselor will tell you
that
I always try I'm always make sure I'm on
the same team as my wife because if
you're on the other team the part of me
that wants to win takes over and then
I'm like yeah what welcome to my love
yeah I wish I'd had the counselling
before having to find that out first
person you know it just occurred to me
you had the wedding right after Game
seven what if he was lost would you have
been able to pull it together or would
you been a real dick at the whole Wed at
the wedding seriously would you be like
walking down the island I do you know we
talked about that and we just kept
saying hey it's it's it's for a good
reason it's for a good reason but thank
God we won yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you